[Music]
we are 1688 let's see if we can cross
1700 and we have a black game against
the 1699.
great e3 okay so e3 is not in and of
itself a bad move the way that i like to
respond is is by playing d5 okay d3 so
this is probably going to be a hippo
okay knight d2 yeah this is this is
seems like a reverse hippo i'm not going
to go through you know our preferred
setup again i'm just going to play the
moves
you know those of you who have been
watching carefully know that i like a
particular arrangement of pieces which
involves not putting the knight on c6
but who can tell me
real fast
what is the
sort of defining characteristic
of the setup that i like to adopt
against these types of openings
i like to play them upon c6 and the
point and we can play it immediately and
then put the bishop on d6 or we can
start with bishop d6 and then play c6
okay or we can castle first it really
doesn't matter i don't know what white's
doing it's this isn't even a hippo but
that doesn't change our setup we're
still going to go with our our preferred
setup
and the point of c6 is to build a pawn
chain so that when white fianchetto is
their bishop
it uh stares right you know it's biting
on granite okay so let's castle
now you might ask well what do we do
about this knight
and once again if you've watched
carefully you know that very often this
knight goes to d7 and then it swings
around via f8 to g6 so as not to block
the bishop now in order to get this
knight to g6 what additional move
might we want to make and i think we're
going to make this move now because it's
a very flexible move and we don't know
exactly how it's going to develop uh his
king side so
i i think it it makes sense to start
with a flexible move rookie and just
reinforcing the center and depending on
how white positions uh his or her pieces
okay so g4
so this is actually not such a bad setup
that our opponent is adopting it's
kind of like a hippo on steroids
and um
we have to be very careful if we go
knight bd7 we can get our knight trapped
why can go g5 there
so in that sense rookie might have been
not the most accurate move
um and there's many ways that we can
that we can go around that
i'm gonna do something
a little bit that looks a little bit
strange rather than developing the
knight to beat to d7
we're gonna develop it to a6 and then
bring it back into the center via c7
we're gonna do this
if that makes sense and then later the
knight can go out to e6
at jess thank you for the tier one now
what what move on the queen side should
we make at some point let's play it now
which grabs space it prevents certain um
expansion ideas on the queen side yeah
so let's throw an a5 just just for uh
just for fun and also it discourages
white from castling queen side because
if white castle's queen side now
um we'd drop our knight back to d7
that's why we left this square open
that's why we didn't put the other
knight to d7 and we're not worried and
white's not threatening h5 i'm not
worried about the quote-unquote attack
with that being said we shouldn't leave
these knights here forever especially
because the bishop is blocked so what
i'd like to do now
is i'd like to be able to meet knight f3
with bishop g4
so what we're going to do is get our
knight to c5 which is a nice
central square
we're not afraid of b4 because of knight
a4 we're not afraid of d4 that's a
really bad move because
some genius decided to put their rook on
e8
okay but this opens up the e file and
this plays right into our hands
now we might ask how can we exploit the
e file yeah we have this x-ray going
against the queen well one of the best
ways to exploit an x-ray is to put a
knight on a square that was formerly
defended by this pawn
so we have a couple of moves like that
we can go knight b5 but i think an even
sexier approach is to go knight seven e6
and then try to get this knight over to
f4 which is the sort of
you know prime real estate you know
mansion in malibu kind of square knife
f4 yeah i'll definitely explain after
the game why i'm not worried about the
king side attack
and this usually leads to further
tactics just putting the knight on f4 in
many types of positions you can almost
guarantee yourself that you are going to
have some sort of a tactic to follow and
sure enough if you look very carefully
you identify the undefended pieces
you'll find the move well either knight
to d3 it doesn't really matter we can
bring this knight to d3 and not only do
we win a pawn but we totally just
destroy white's uh queen side pawn cover
and we force the king to move so we do a
lot of good things in one
okay now that is total self-destruction
and this is a great example of not
playing automatically most people here
would immediately grab the bishop on b2
but one of the things you have to start
doing you know as a 1700
thank you chess dojo for the raid is is
you just always got to look for a better
move right you don't want to play
automatically unless you're low on time
and just by me saying that
i think most of you already see the
possibility of winning the queen of
bishop g4
just by not playing automatically you're
already opening your eyes to a lot of
these additional option options
and this was a total collapse by white
at the end but it was already back
now i will admit that i probably didn't
play
ideally in the opening
and
if i were playing a classical game if i
were playing a game at my level
i would probably adopt a slightly
different setup i would probably go
knight c6
and then bring the pawn to f5 and play
sort of an austrian attack setup if we
think of this as a reverse perk this is
essentially just an austrian attack
setup but i wanted to be consistent with
the setup that i've adopted previously
and so we decided to play the one with
bishop d6 and c6 not that there's
anything wrong with this this is still
very solid
yeah i have speed run games on the perk
so you can definitely check that out
okay so first interesting moment is here
again don't go knight bd7 because of g5
so
that's why we we found an alternate
route for the knight to c7 now why was i
not afraid let's take this moment why
was i not afraid of the king side attack
well
first of all
um
you can think of it this way there is a
very long
delta between
sorry that's the wrong word there's a
very wide
gap between g5 and eight pawns on g5 and
h4 don't mean that you're gonna get
checkmated i think a lot of players
especially beginners
they think that at the moment that
somebody plays h4 g4 they're already
checkmated that's it you can administer
the last rights and
you know you can shovel dirt on yourself
but there's a very very long time before
white actually converts this into
anything
and to show you that let's imagine that
black just goes back and forth for a
bunch of moves i'm just gonna go knight
f8 and knight d7
how does white even get
you know how does white even convert
this into an attack well first of all
white can't go h5
because that blower is the g pawn so
white has to defend the g pawn now
theoretically this would already allow
us to get bishop g4 and throwing a
monkey wrench into white's whole
attacking design because now e4 is a
threat but for the sake of argument
let's say the black continues to go back
and forth presumably you would go h5
right and then presumably
you would go g6
so first of all if we take this position
concretely black can just take on g6 but
even if we were to go h6 which is the
sort of classical method of dealing with
g6
is white anywhere close to even
you know the checkmate is
you know a word that
that doesn't exist here
we're not white is not even close and
the reason why it's not close is because
white's pieces are not properly arranged
in order to they're not coordinated at
all
white doesn't have any good pieces on
the king's side and just because the
rook is staring at the spawn doesn't
mean anything
so
i think the the key lesson from
these kinds of games is that you don't
need to be afraid of attacks that
that that that quote-unquote attacks
that come out of nowhere an attack has
to be set up properly by good peace
coordination the presence of pieces on
the side of the board that you're
getting attacked in
and you know if you're a 17 1800 you got
to start calling people's bluff
you know this kind of style can't scare
you anymore and sometimes you just gotta
continue playing as you would normally
play and call your opponent as well and
see that nothing happens
rather than saying oh crap h4 i'm
getting checkmate and when people panic
what often happens paradoxically is i
see a lot of people making moves on the
king's side like you might panic and go
g6 this is exactly how you get
checkmated you make a move on the king
side so for that reason we just ignore
we go knight c5 and knight c5 has a
point again in case of knight f3 we're
preparing to play bishop g4
does that make sense so d4 is total
self-destruction
similarly b4 would allow the knight to
worm into a4 which is a terribly nasty
square
yarrow thank you for the tier three
white is kind of out of moves here it's
very hard for white to even play a move
because because of how passive it is
well the dark sky white was nowhere near
doubling the rooks in that position
so i don't see a move for white here in
a white castle's queenside which maybe
white should have tried which maybe
white should have tried
now black on the other hand has
a
solid fundamentals we have a good center
a good center allows us to
marshal our forces between the two sides
of the board we have active pieces and
if we play a move like queen e7 we have
a target we can attack the a3 pawn we
can use our pawns our attack on the
queen's head is actually going to be
dangerous
it's actually going to be dangerous we
might even move this knight away from c5
in order to open up the battery against
the a3 pawn then we might push a4 when
the moment is right
we might also do something i've done in
a previous speedrun game which is
for example
we can even go a4 and after b4 who can
tell me
uh who can spot a very creative tactical
idea this seems very counterproductive
obvious and it usually is but i think in
this specific instance
if if you know what you're doing on the
queen side
provoking before can actually be a good
thing
not knight b3 it's way too early to
sacrifice the knight although the the
correct move prepares a nice sacrifice
but if you're sacking a knight you
better remove you better get rid of all
of white's queen side pawns so think
about how you can use your minor pieces
to break through white's pawn shell very
good knight a6 frankfurt airport move
and then you just want to take on b4
and and crash through with a3 for
example you're gonna have two pawns for
the piece the other knights coming to b5
the queen's
dropping into a5
notice how all of black's pieces are
nicely clustered on the on the right
side of the board literally and
figuratively
so this is a cool idea this a4 and the
knight back
to
to be able then to sacrifice on a4
i wonder if i can look for
an example of something like that
although i i kind of doubt it
no i i found a couple of examples
this is as you can see a game of two
very strong french players roland is a
grand both of them are grandmasters now
i think in the time at the time the game
is played they're probably ims
so
this is the position which occurred on
the board
now you can see that white is the king
on the queen side and
i like what black did here
black drops the queen back to b6 in
order to open up the gates for the pawn
and then black sends the pawn down the
board a5
white goats d3 chasing the knight away
black says no problem
and and here's the instructive moment
why plays a3
and what did black do in this position
and if you've been paying attention you
should be able to you basically already
know what black did
now white thinks that he's stopping a4
that's what white thinks
but he's not no guys you knight takes b3
is not the move it's too early to sack
on b3 the problem is you sack on b3 and
what do i always say don't be fooled
into thinking that just because you have
a queen in the attack that means the
attack is working why can't just go
queen e2 and then queen c queen c2
the move is a4
as i as i showed b4 knight a6
it's literally one to one the same idea
now black doesn't sack on b4 immediately
but he does in a couple of moves so what
should black do first in order to soften
up the b4 pawn first you gotta soften up
that pawn a little bit and open up the
queen side further with the move c5 and
white play c3 and here we go take steak
stick boom
and after queen before king e2 the point
of the sacrifice actually isn't even
made
what is the point of the sacrifice what
does black gain
uh in return for the sacrifice and black
wins the game in two more moves
so think about it look at the queen side
what have we gained we gotten two
passers black bushes a3
92 knight b5 and white simply resigned
here because the knight is and it's not
even premature i mean the night may be a
little bit premature but the knight's
coming into c3
and the queen's coming to b2 and the
pawn is coming to a2 this is completely
lost white till queen side is gone and
there's no way to coordinate the pieces
sufficiently so here you see a strong i
am defeated by this idea
and i can show you more but i think you
get the point
so most of the ideas that i show are
you can find parallels in real games and
here you can do the exact same thing you
can go knight a6 and then c5
so anyways after y plays d4 the game is
basically over we go 96 knight f4 and
this is total devastation
total devastation
it was like 22 moves
now obviously white should take on d3
and then go king f1 because if white
goes king d1 here we can still go bishop
g4
but then we play knight takes p2 the
knight is easily evacuated via d3
or defended via bishop e5 so the knight
is unassailable here
this is this is really really bad for
white obviously what white should have
gone for is something like this and the
game goes on but it's a lot it's lost
i still don't get bishop g4
so i assume you mean you don't get why
bishop g4 is good
well it's because this creates a pin
against the knight and threatens e4 i
assume you're familiar with the concept
of a pin
and this pin is very good because
it's an actionable pin you can actually
intensify the pressure on the knight
oh bishop g4 in the end
well it's a deflection sacrifice this is
the pin
so if white doesn't do anything you take
the queen
if white takes the bishop then you take
on f2 and this is a fork
this is a classic concept
does that make sense so this is now you
might say well why couldn't we take on
f2 immediately because the queen defends
that square you have to get the queen
onto a forkable square using a pin
so both the pin and the fork play a role
in this combination
okay great
all right fantastic i think that that
was a good con
instructive game
why can't white take the knight with a
pawn well because the queen is hanging
and i explained i mean of course white
should take here but then we recapture
with a fork
alright let's make it to 1700
let's make it to 1700.
[Music]
you